chapter 28 is about where the story has
gone from one of the previous chapters d
like with literal religion remember when
we talked about liberal religion of
liberal Christianity and we talked about
the Renaissance all those sorts of
things these guys are picking those
themes up and a lot of this is actually
taking place in New England but it
becomes as a lot of things in New
England are very important parts of the
American character the American story
and the concepts of Americans have
themselves was actually kind of funny
catch phrase at all it's buried late in
the chapter but i'll read it to right
now it's about the Universalists and
they say Universalists were were said to
believe in the Fatherhood of God that's
one thing the brotherhood of man and the
neighborhood of Boston why because they
were so centered in in New England
especially around the urban area Boston
was at that time arrival from New York
for being one of the most important
cities in the United States obviously in
our time everyone New York right New
York one a long time ago but but at that
time Boston was of equal importance to
to New York if not greater importance so
we're looking at little movements and
what I particularly like about teaching
this stuff is it's not just about
religion so I actually about philosophy
quite a few of the people that we're
going to look at fit into the the
history of American philosophies
transcendentalist for example Jonathan
Edwards first American philosopher these
guys are coming several generations
later and they're in certain ways ears
of Jonathan Edwards and there is a
distinctively American philosophical
tradition I actually went to a school
that specialized in that when I was
when I was a graduate student and so I
you know there's this is it's kind of
nice to know about this this sort of
stuff and how philosophy and religion
intersected with each other so your book
starts up by talking about religious
liberalism and we've already talked
about that quite a bit so I I want to
skip over some of that discussion there
is a tension that it brings up though
and that's between we want to use really
as simple words between freedom and
structure um liberalism understood in
terms of religion in terms of culture in
terms of politics is usually for more
freedom for not having somebody telling
you from the top down how you got the
cave doesn't always work out that way
sometimes liberals actually end up you
know becoming something sort of like
their own form of fascists he's actually
a great book out there called liberal
fascism like jonah goldberg which makes
a case for that sort of thing but in
general the idea is to let people do
what they want to do let them find what
works for them let them figure out in
terms of religion what they actually
resonate with and just because people
decided something in the past doesn't
mean that we're committed to it forever
you know we can we can change things to
suit new times to suit new problems that
we hadn't thought that's that's inherent
in the liberal idea now what happens if
you let anybody do anything they want
but let's say we get away from religion
for a minute how many of you belong to
Clause of one form or another on campus
okay is there a structure to them like
do you have officers and there's
certainly a doing things what happens if
you don't stick to the structure house
up
yeah even being able to like hold a
meeting you can't have everybody talking
at the same time there has to be a
certain way of doing things I mean some
of them may actually is like
parliamentary procedure then it gets
really complicated but most of the time
you know you have a few officers the
officers actually like set the agenda
you meet at a certain time not just
whenever anybody feels like it in their
dorm room you know you can't have
complete freedom you need some level of
structure Ross things will fall apart
and these you know these are kind of
tough to reconcile each other because
every time you make a rule it some
people are going to be upset right
because you're impinging out their
freedom how many do you see in problems
in some of the clubs that you're in
where people get that out of shape
because somebody's actually enforcing a
rule thank you I am you know if you
don't that's a pretty good club or at
least you're having a good run it's the
same thing for these religious
communities and your book talks about
two parallel religious movements
emerging out of New England primarily
and they have to deal with this problem
that's going to come up over and over
again so keep that in your mind as we're
going through all of us now these two
communities are the Universalists and
the Unitarians
and I sort of deliberately resisted the
urge to put unitarians over here because
everybody always thinks the Unitarians
are much more important unitarians were
really dominant in American culture in
New England for a while and not only
dominant culture but also they do tend
to be from the upper class so that that
helped out quite a bit as well
universalist tended to be more lower to
middle class nowadays they're actually
both part of the one same church the
Unitarian Universalist Church so if you
look at you know for that today they
merged back in the 1960s and we'll talk
about that bit of the story in a few
moments so the units here is let's turn
over that's what r your book starts they
trace the religious roots to to
Reformation free spirits and then they
were also influenced by your book says
the emergence in England beginning of
the seventeenth century the small group
of Christians who deny that God existed
is through people unitarians their units
hearings in opposition to trinitarianism
trinitarianism says that God is three
persons father son Holy Spirit the
Trinity right that's what most
Christians are and have done throughout
throughout history there have been some
some groups like we talked about the
earrings you know long time ago who had
denied the divinity of Christ they would
have been Unitarians so some people
actually saw the unitarian movement as a
new type of Arianism which that's really
debatable but in any case that's one of
their central tenets that there isn't a
Trinity and what happens historically is
the Great Awakening up in New England
we've got this this history of the new
lights the ones who are more emotional
you know the ones who are taking their
inspiration from the newer theology
many of these opponents the old lines
and the old lights are concentrated in
Boston and the other people are
concentrated out in the hinterland the
rural areas what happens is that the old
lights becomes something completely
different when we hear old we kind of
think conservative they're going to you
know stick with what they've got so you
know for the Puritans that would have
been Calvinism right John Calvin is
notion of predestination all the other
things that goes along with that they
start to become critical of that as well
so they're critical of the emotional
heart oriented worship they're also
critical of Calvinism and the end up
doing their own sort of thing like your
book Franzen the most conspicuous
teaching of the movement that took shape
with the denial that God is a Trinity
more important ones are equally to
determine assault on the calvinist
stress an all-pervasive corrupting power
of original sin and its corollary God's
/ destiny of all humanity for salvation
and damnation so they're rejecting
something really key to the narrative as
they seen it so far they're rejecting
they're saying that that God is 13
they're rejecting original sin we're
rejecting predestination and let's think
about some of the corollaries that go
along with this your book talks about
this but let's just sort of puzzle these
out ourselves good exercise so if God is
one what's this Jesus guy yeah that
would be one way to look at it and
that's actually the way in which Islam
earlier form of this I don't want to say
movement is are not directly connected
together but the tendency would frame it
unitarians didn't think of him so much
as a prophet actually let's hold off on
that / decided we can see this he's you
that's it he's not a he's not God he's
not he's not the Son of God in a sort of
metaphysical sense for the Unitarians
and then we'll think about what he might
be in relation to this rejecting of
original sin so if you reject the notion
of original sin that human beings are
screwed up and pervasive ways that can't
be overcome by self-help books or taking
the right you know medication or you
know just decided to fix your life or
changing society but no matter what you
do human beings end up being screwed up
if you reject that notion what are you
left with human beings are fundamentally
good right and the goal that is to quit
being such jerks to each other and start
you know doing things more rationally
and you know learn how to be ethical as
we say so if that's one of the key goals
who's this Jesus guy it's not a prophet
what is role of death remember he's
wandering around saying things to crowds
and you know leaving an example yeah but
preacher what's he preaching that's very
good you're on the right track you're
not preaching stuff about don't mix the
meeting thierry like the kosher law as a
matter of fact you know they're the
early Christians end up rejecting the
culture so what is what's left after you
take away all the ceremonial stuff yeah
stories of all of intolerance yeah shows
in some other stories to which arcs so
much about love and tolerance but they
are about right and wrong right and what
how should you behave yeah think about
the Sermon on the Mount and some of the
stuff that this guy says it just blows
people's minds like you know if you
your brother wrongs you don't take him
to court because the judges you know
might actually lock you both up it was
paraphrasing or it's a sin some people
say that that you know you shouldn't
kill I say that you shouldn't even feel
anger towards your brother and that if
you call you on Rocco which basically
translates into jackass or fool or
something like that you're actually
doing a terrible thing basically like
killing them that's a very tough moral
code to live up to Jesus is all about
ethics in that case all about how to
limit that are right and now if you
reject predestination what is that so
predestination was this idea that
everybody is either going individually
not as a whole everyone's either going
to the good place or the bad place and
there's nothing you can do about if
you're going to the good place we'll
figure that out because you're living a
good life for going to the bad place
even if you want to be a good person
you're still going to help won't take
that away now what are you left with
what's the opposite of that in terms of
through your spiritual path free will
you get to control where you go you
decide whether you're a good person or a
bad person whether you developer
degenerate yeah so this is all heard of
these are all corollaries to this and
that's what the Unitarians really
emphasized your book talks about a few
important characters in here one would
be this William Ellery Channing who
preaches this sermon about the unity of
God and his parental character the
single human nature of Jesus individual
free will the moral and ethical
character of the Christian religion all
the things that we just talked about it
amenities they start to form into the
American unitarian Association and the
next person on the scene is particularly
important to I think some of you may
have read is Ralph Ralph Waldo Emerson
I've been even read any of his essays
your least heard of them right he's a
he's also transcendentalist figure you
might have you know your American Lit
class come across him he gives this this
divinity school address he had in it
he's um questioning the miracles
attributed to Jesus in the Gospels now
why would he be doing that sort of like
Thomas Jefferson right Jefferson Bible
take out all the miracles why would you
want to do that well you know the idea
is if the world by itself is already
sort of inhabited by by God and pervaded
by God you don't need miracles why did
God make things rest on what happened
with just this person at this time why
wouldn't God it will offer a message
that's universally accessible to
everybody through through nature an
emerson leads us to something else that
kind of fits in here in the middle and
that's this transcendentalism
transcendentalism is a little bit
shorter lived you don't get a
transcendentalist church out of this you
have a transcendentalist movement so
Emerson would be a key guy in this Henry
David Thoreau may be read Walden in high
school or middle school now good book
worth reading he's out there and he goes
out usually people read it nowadays
because they want to be like back to
nature sorts they want to be like the RO
get themselves a little shack somewhere
and you knows can things and hang out
and mix with other people not you in a
bomber style but you know more like
happy style but if we throw the goal was
to strip away civilization so you can
hear the voice of God out there in
nature and sort of have this this
religious experience he has a bright a
lot about 12 buys and what he makes it
was not quite so much religion is might
respect but but it's worth reading the
transcendentalist are coming from it's a
philosophical weather coming from the
transcendental philosophy which is
coming from Germany through England so
if you remember back to your intro to
philosophy class if you have that kind
people like a body all comments if you
read again very tough read hard to
figure out what he's talking about even
for us college professors oh it wasn't
hard for you and I sure don't believe
there you go then maybe you should be
teaching we may have a recruit anyway
that this this philosophy says here's a
great summary of a new book the central
emphasis of transcendentalism was on the
human ability to enter into deeper more
original relationship with the ultimate
reality that underlies appearances and
is present
that's the transcendental and so how do
how do humans beings experience that
well it could be through intuition could
be through music and art work some some
people got into using drugs to try to
access this that you know the hippies
would have the first want us to think
about you know doing that sort of thing
they actually took some of their cues
from a few of the fringe people with
this human history customs and
institutions including organized
religion hindered rather than help this
quest so you'd want to get away from
that in order to experience divinity to
experience God or whatever it is that
you're looking for the spiritual so
Emerson and Thoreau are essential of
this and talked about a few other people
who kind of fit in with that including
some where our critics or satirizing it
like Nathaniel Hawthorne you might have
come across from Herman Melville twice
about the fireside poets you probably
haven't read them because very few
people do read them anymore but then it
also talks about going back unitarianism
what were these people about their
they're about progress they're about
before they're about some of the things
we've been talking about another other
chapters now we want to look at
universalism universalism is a little
bit easier to sum up universalism what's
the universal in that might put JC so I
don't rank the whole word out everybody
knows JC is right not jcpenney ok the
universal one this is God is gonna save
everybody and they aren't Christians so
they think that that Jesus is involved
in this somehow eventually that starts
the gate kind of fuzzy and more about
God saving everybody so universalists
will say things like well
it really exists or some would say hell
is just for a little while and that you
get you know get out of it after you've
done your time which makes us know a lot
more like purgatory doesn't it the long
and short of it is is that the review of
God is very optimistic loving God will
will save every single human being no
matter how bad your book talks about a
few key documents and thinkers as hosea
ballou writes a treatise of atonement
the winchester profession and they've
actually become the Universalist Church
of America they are not as well healed
as the the Unitarians but they and they
actually have a lot of growth at the
beginning not so much later on they
actually shrink a bit by the 1960s and
that's really telescoping a lot of time
both of these groups have realized that
they're really on the same page about
most of their doctrines and most of what
they're interested in that they have
parallel organizations that they're
spending a lot of money on this and that
it might be better for them to actually
just merge and become the Unitarian
Universalists that's what happens so
when you see a universe when you see a
unitarian church today it's really a
Unitarian Universalist Church